Utilizamos medidores de oxígeno en alta mar
que nos informan continuamente sobre los niveles de oxígeno.
Y cuando buceamos, se ven muchos peces.
Miles de peces, de todo tipo,
incluyendo a mi amigo aquí, la barracuda que vi un día.
Mis compañeros fueron por un lado y yo fui por este otro con mi cámara.
(Ríe)
Y luego, unos 10 m más abajo, se empiezan a ver menos peces.
Y luego, al llegar al fondo,
ya no se ve ningún pez.
No hay vida en la plataforma, no hay seres vivos por allí.
Y eso indica que uno está en la zona muerta.
Y, ¿cuál es la conexión entre el centro de EE. UU.
y el golfo de México?
Gran parte de la cuenca está formada por tierras agrícolas,
en particular de cultivos de rotación de maíz y soja.
El nitrógeno y el fósforo de los fertilizantes van al suelo,
se escurren, ingresan al río Misisipi
y terminan en el golfo de México.
Hay actualmente tres veces más nitrógeno en las aguas del Misisipi
que en la década de 1950.
Tres veces.
Y el fósforo se ha duplicado.
Y la consecuencia es más fitoplancton,
más veleros que se hunden y menos oxígeno.
Esta no es una característica natural del golfo,
sino consecuencia de la actividad humana.
El paisaje ya no es lo que era.
Había praderas, bosques, humedales,
áreas con patos y todo tipo de cosas.
Pero ya no; ahora hay cultivos en hileras.
Estas prácticas agrícolas se pueden mejorar
usando menos fertilizantes, tal vez mediante la fertilización de precisión,
e implementando una agricultura sostenible,
como el pasto perenne de trigo, que tiene raíces mucho más largas
que los 15 cm de una planta de maíz,
y puede mantener el nitrógeno en la tierra y evitar que el suelo se erosione.
¿Y cómo convencemos a nuestros vecinos del norte,
a 1600 km de distancia o más,
de que sus actividades perjudican la calidad del agua en el golfo de México?
En primer lugar, podemos llevarlos a su propio patio trasero.
Si uno quiere ir a nadar a Wisconsin en el verano
a nuestra laguna favorita,
pueden encontrarnos con algo así,
que parece pintura verde derramada y huele a eso,
y crece en la superficie del agua.
Esta es una proliferación de algas tóxicas, de un color verde azulado,
que no son nada buenas para los humanos.
También, hace un par de veranos, la superficie del lago Eire se cubrió
de estas algas verde azuladas, cubriendo cientos de kilómetros;
y la ciudad de Toledo, en Ohio, no pudo abastecerse de agua
durante varios días seguidos.
Y si miramos las noticias,
veremos que muchas comunidades tienen problemas con el agua potable.
Soy científica,
--no sé si se nota.
(Risas)
Y hago ciencia sólida, publico mis resultados,
mis colegas los leen, citan mi trabajo.
Pero realmente creo que, como científica
que usa principalmente fondos federales para investigar,
me debo al público,
a jefes de organismos y miembros del congreso,
con quienes debo compartir mi conocimiento
para que puedan usarlo, espero, para tomar mejores decisiones
sobre nuestra política ambiental.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Una de las formas de lograrlo fue convocando a los medios.
Y Joby Warrick del "Washington Post"
puso esta foto en un artículo
en la primera plana del periódico, un domingo por la mañana.
Fue una excelente estrategia.
Y el senador John Breaux, de Louisiana,
dijo: "Dios mío, ¿así piensan que es el golfo de México?"
Y yo dije: "Bueno, ahí está la prueba,
y tenemos que hacer algo al respecto".
Al mismo tiempo, la senadora de Maine, Olympia Snowe,
tenía problemas con la proliferación de algas nocivas en el golfo de Maine.
Y entonces unieron fuerzas --fue una acción bipartidista--
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
y me invitaron a hablar en el Congreso,
y dije, "Lo único que hice fue perseguir cangrejos por el sur de Texas,
No sé cómo hacer eso."
(Risas)
Pero lo hice.
(Aclamaciones)
Finalmente, el proyecto de ley se aprobó,
y recibió el nombre de... ¡sí, sí!
Ley de Investigación y Control de la Proliferación de Algas Nocivas
e Hipoxia de 1998.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Por eso la llamamos simplemente "proyecto de ley Snowe-Breaux".
(Risas)
También hubo una conferencia en 2001
organizada por la Academia Nacional de Ciencias
que trató el tema de los fertilizantes, el nitrógeno y la mala calidad del agua.
Nuestro oradora plenaria fue la exgobernadora
del estado de Nueva Jersey.
Y ella...
sin duda hablaba muy en serio cuando miraba a la audiencia,
y pensé: "Seguramente me mira a mí".
"Estoy harta de que a esto se lo compare con Nueva Jersey.
Elijan otro estado, cualquier estado, simplemente no quiero oírlo más".
Pero ella fue capaz de activar el plan de acción
en la agenda del presidente George H. W. Bush
para fijar objetivos ambientales
y trabajar para resolverlos.
La región del Midwest no alimenta al mundo.
Alimenta a muchas gallinas, cerdos, ganado
y genera el etanol que usamos en la gasolina,
que está regulado por la política federal.
Podemos hacerlo mejor.
Debemos tomar decisiones
que nos hagan menos consumistas
y reduzcan nuestra dependencia del nitrógeno.
Podemos contrarrestar el impacto ecológico
reduciendo nuestro consumo de nitrógeno.
En mi caso, contribuyo comiendo poca carne
--aunque algo me gusta de vez en cuando--
evitando el uso de aceite de maíz,
conduciendo un auto que puede funcionar a gasolina sin etanol
y que permite un mejor rendimiento de combustible.
Cosas como esas pueden marcar la diferencia.
Así que los desafío, no solo a Uds.,
sino a muchas personas, en especial a las de la región del Midwest,
a que piensen en cómo manejan su tierra y cómo pueden marcar la diferencia.
Y mis pasos son muy pequeños.
Para cambiar el tipo de agricultura en EE. UU.
será necesario dar grandes pasos.
Y se necesitará voluntad política y social para que eso suceda.
Pero podemos hacerlo.
Creo firmemente que podemos transformar la ciencia en un puente hacia la acción
y marcar una diferencia en nuestro medioambiente.
Todos queremos un medioambiente limpio.
Y podemos trabajar juntos para lograrlo
para que ya no existan estas zonas muertas en el golfo de México.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)